hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to simulacra you've got
something on your eyeball
it was a little dusty if you remember
similacra it's the game that is mostly
played through a phone
not like feed vid which is a very good
game but i have played simulacra one
this is similar
to
choose how your journey began
well i mean i gotta go with noir mark i
gotta go with noir regulire you're a
junior detective and a hardcore skeptic
you're a tablet nah you're a junior
detective and a hardcore skeptic don't
poke your nose in that
i no i don't care if you're on overtime
[Music]
so you keep saying you're ready for the
big stuff i am ready well today's your
lucky day huh
doesn't feel so lucky
awards won't get you respect
look you're the only one around this
whole damn place i can trust
everyone else is too
set in their way of thinking
i like to think outside the box thanks
for recognizing
this is a secret operation no that's a
phone
shut oh
anyone finds out about this and our
careers are toast
turn the phone on when you're out of the
station and alone
i'll give you more instructions soon
okay sounds good i could say it's a
matter of life and death but uh
i'm afraid it's more than that more than
life and death huh don't screw this up
i'll try not to
see you around chief
or whatever that is
okay so i'm a junior detective why was
that a difference though that's what i
don't know
why would that have mattered
oh god
[Music]
okay cool
what did all that mean was that so
supposed to be like some kind of a
choice tree at the beginning there oh
there seems to be a bit of a problem
detective morillo test test
great it works why are you testing me
texting me on this phone i got a fresh
murder cases
i need your help okay you got it
detective marillo i am very
uncomfortable in this chair right now so
that is not the correct time though that
is not the correct date
why is it whoa hello
hey
oh god
uh oh
okay i'm just gonna set this up
are you guys ready yes get in place get
in place okay
and
okay let's go for it let's go for it
getting close getting close
in three
two
one
there's no light i'm not sure if that
went off
should i should i go check it
okay give me a moment give it a moment
okay okay i'm gonna take a look at it
oh it was a video
okay well that was um invasion of
privacy namaste you guys
that's really strange
all right
interesting this is all my fault
i saw all the signs but i just wrote
them off
it was just so much easier to believe
that i was just imagining
things i didn't know we'd get this down
no it's gonna be dangerous i felt it
i can feel it coming from me
and i think it's watching me
and i think it wants to hurt me okay or
worse okay
i have to stop this thing
before it's too late
okay sounds good did you do it
did you stop it
hope you did
yoga
yoga food yoga
swimming
pictures uh
scan
oh
this photo is corrupted and cannot be
deleted from the factory reset restore
point created i didn't know that i was
supposed to do that i saw on that on the
other thing and it didn't do anything
there was something here
here
maya distress the self-recording of maya
looking distressed something seems to be
coming for her and she blames herself
for it
okay so i got those clues i don't even
didn't even know that i was looking for
clues i just had a funny feeling that i
should probably look through the seat hi
detective morillo i got a fresh murder
case that's way over my head need your
help all right
wild secrecy
well i'm desperate the chief closed the
case in less than a week
said it was an open and shut accidental
death they just want to hit this month's
quota instead of doing a proper job what
a disgrace
wow
the department's really efficient
are you blind
they're just rushing through the
caseload
it's those damn budget cuts i'm telling
you
i need to this case reopened by force if
necessary so i borrowed the only
evidence i
need the victim's phone which you have
right now
good
not the first time i have blown through
a few case loads if you know what i mean
you're going rogue
i dedicated my life to serving justice
i'll bend any rule to make that happen
the investigation was a whole load of
incompetent police work
slip shot evidence collection bad
interviewing practices i don't even know
why they bothered my gut told me to look
further and this phone proves me right
so
how did she die
officially
a heart attack
her name was maya well lexie do a
flashback to maya from the first
simulacra
we received an anonymous call of a
disturbance at her apartment responding
officer found her dead don't you think
that was too convenient to tip off i
really feel that there has to be foul
play here what are your leads
yeah if anyone that trusts their gut
more than me it's you and if it's more
than you it's me and i'm not making a
lot of sense nothing concrete but listen
that video she left seems like she knew
something bad was going to happen have
you seen it oh yeah i scanned it with
warden
way ahead of you pal
showing initiative
i like that in a rookie thanks rookie
looks like someone or something was
stalking her anything sticks out
to you
this is all my fault
before it's too late
well nothing stands out here for sure
yes not that
uh
nope not a thing what is all this
homicide vice cybercrimes pet rescue
what is this
[Music]
system restore i'll get that in a second
ah no i'll reconstruct it
drag and drop clue file here
oh
whoa
i'm restoring it's very tinny my ears
holy [ __ ]
hi maya you're looking very not creepy
she's blaming herself for something
you think she caused her own death
but what could she have done to feel
hunted down in her own home reminds me
of some of my stranger cases huh
i've seen a lot of crazy things in my
time this doesn't even rank in the top
10. who's the video addressed to
up to us to find out
i'm assigning you to the department of
obscure phenomena
a discreet team within the four solving
cases involving the supernatural and the
unknown
dupe
dupe
really offline what do you mean offline
damn it
never mind the name it's just us both on
this so we have to work fast first thing
is to restore the phone
the ward nap is really something
hang on how did you manage to use it and
restore the data i mean i
i just
i did
are you spying on me as your supervisor
it's my duty
i can see whatever warden recovers
so i can get up to speed immediately
what
[Music]
uh since the department is pinching
pennies
i'll be conducting this training manual
for our new app
it's called uh
and nevermind you know what i'm talking
about
this app is a powerful data recovery
tool and clue detection tool
it does this by encrypting
blowfish
which is uh wait
a cryptology
what is important is
this app can scan pieces of information
and offer us new pieces of information
you just click here
on this button to start a scan
and the results will pop in this
space here
you can then sort through the recovered
data to find possibly crucial evidence
for your case
to exit just press the home button here
as you can see
this simple but sophisticated technology
will help the force do our jobs better
and faster
you expect me to believe this guy is the
guy that i'm texting right now and is
instructing me on all of this stuff i
look like an idiot
yes thank you but also how do you expect
me to believe that this is actually this
guy talking to me at this juncture
because i do not believe that that is so
and i do not believe that this is the
case i don't even think he would know
how to send me that this training manual
explains this more advanced feature you
can have a look at it in your own time
you're brighter than i thought keep this
up and we'll solve this case in no time
you need to know the details of the
crime scene as well it's all in the case
file i'll go look at the gaze file then
goodbye
mail
ah
namaste and greetings to you my i'm
afraid that we have to retract our
invitation to connect with you appears
that our trust quotient among our
audience is shrunk and we cannot permit
any possible polluting influences at our
event it's bad for the vibes oh i've
been thinking about what you said i'm
gonna go ahead and ask for likes from my
fans
huh i know it's not the most popular
thing to do but you know how desperate
things are with my family and i am
desperate and i'm never asking them for
help whatever comes out my way i'm going
to fight it i refuse to let what people
say affect my decisions these are my
fans and i trust them by the way i'm not
done asking for permission and i've
already done it
good for you there's nothing wrong with
asking people to like this video
extremely immediately right now that's a
perfectly reasonable thing to ask and i
am asking it right now for you to like
this video because it probably doesn't
do anything anyway but if you like it
somehow
it will help my family
please
i'm begging you
aria park aria is willing to fight for
what she thinks she deserves in this
case not asking for help from her family
even though she needs it that's not what
i got about things
oh i thought you were saying like you
never asked for likes from your fans in
the beginning never mind what i say
don't help my family
i don't want to talk to them you only
like me and not them whatever you do
don't go to my mom's instagram oh
anti-harassment friend rex is getting
trolled given that trolls are a part of
social media we suggest that your friend
adopts more resilience to deal with them
okay
all right
you hear that everybody there's nothing
that could possibly be done about trolls
and bots just get some more brazilians
put some points in resilience
uh mai's one of the very few people that
rex sees as a friend
okay i don't know who rex is
i don't know what any of that is chats
hello
all right you block this content contact
why
is that a penis is this a penis is this
a penis is that a penis lixian d blur
this photo do it
do it
people are that photo
i want to see it with my own eyes
gross i'm one of the best guys grab your
hand and play sanchez just accept my
wild beating heart my love
i hope you're happy reaping on my
freaking heart you you you heartless
witch
you could be sorry when i kill myself
and then and then we'll see how many
people who think you're such a great
star huh
all right a lot of creepies a lot of
creepos a lot of creeps all right that
was a waste of time uh
uh emergency services
why would that have been the most recent
thing
who's zach carson
okay
rex keegan
can't talk right now busy being awesome
drop me your deets and i'll holler back
later
oh i thought i was gonna leave a message
my phone number
[Music]
interesting emergency services
[Music]
welcome to emergency services we have
upgraded to a new self-guided response
service to better aid you with your
current crisis press 1 for medical
emergencies
press 2 for fire related emergencies
press 3 for robberies and or break-ins
press 4 for vehicular collisions
press 5 for other incidents or to reach
a live operator
if you are unable to respond please hold
until our geolocation system tracks your
current location
okay
what is up my emergency crew please
consider calling back from a landline
for more effective location tracking or
continue holding
[Music]
death is not the end
of your finances
visit will and will estate planning
today to ensure that your loved ones are
looked after once you make your final
exit what will and will making last
wishes come true since 1808. why would
emergency services have
advertisements on them i don't feel like
they're but it's very important to us
and we endeavor to find you alive
please continue holding
great can't wait for you to find me
alive
wow
oh hey hey hi if that's 9-1-1 why does
9-1-1 have ads why does 9-1-1 need
sponsors aria park
[Applause]
hey sorry i'm super tied up at the
moment i'll return your call asap when i
get a breather okay why does everyone
have music that do their voicemail
should i have music allurin hotline
[Music]
to ask about our brand new loyalty
program press three to ask about our
muse stay on the line
track your location please press zero
three follow up on your application as
our muse please press one learn to want
to be our muse
are you you enough to be a part of us me
and very me pop up stores and get your
applications filled if you have already
applied and want to get in touch with
your talent liaison please dial the four
digit extension number after the beat oh
interesting okay
wait hold on did i have an email
from
ellord i don't think i had any lure no
allure okay but that is something to
keep in mind
for later and i do believe that was the
last number on my thing and i'm not
going to waste any more time doing that
oh wait allure
be true me you be alluring without
allure and could you be yourself you
couldn't you can't you can't you
couldn't you shan't you shouldn't you
would never be able to be you
oh my god
i came raw i saw i conquered all right
whatever no reprints no copies only a
single piece in time just like you you
are your own nfd believe in yourself
like nft bros believe in jpegs believe
believe
your body is a temple let's honor it we
tune your mind train your body and
ensure peak fitness jake the juggernaut
wendy the wonder
the legend alvin
the
almighty
[Applause]
the magnificent okay anyway download
schedule
whoa okay
that's
that is panic attack inducing ah gold
okay that's probably important i think i
don't know your preferred master
my preferred mask marry the magnificent
i know my phone number
i know my phone number i know my number
and i'm gonna write it down here so i
don't have to get it anymore six no zero
six zero
okay so what i gotta do is i gotta go to
surfer i gotta go here i gotta go all
the way to the bottom i gotta i don't
know why i'm doing this i'm just doing
it because it's the only thing that i
can do mary the magnificent phone number
is one five five five nine one
six six oh six oh
sup it
baby
no match the master could not be reached
for my ascension so i really have to try
this for all of these
i would only need to do this if i have a
clue that tells me i'm doing i'm not
gonna just slap my head against the wall
rex keegan
wow get rags rex grab success by the
throat
what
what was that what did i just get
what oh hi hi hi rex
i really didn't want to have to do this
but when the haters try to drag you down
like crabs in a bucket i gotta speak up
mitai kowalski a wannabe activist and my
own personal stalker
this guy thinks i'm some kind of scam
artist as if i need to
you know fool people to make bank
all i know about this schmuck is one he
took my course
two he couldn't hack it and three he
wants to blame everyone but himself
ty is a loser cubicle monkey who's high
in excuses and low on ambition
he knows he can't get better because he
won't put in the work
you know
i'm not even that mad
this guy's life is so sad i'm kind of
sorry for him
okay well good good uh good post buddy
good post definitely not gonna start a
witch hunt there piece of [ __ ] you doxed
me i never did that my followers just
did what they thought was bad
god where have i seen this strategy
before
where have i
hmm where have i seen this strategy of
blame offset before hey
thank you for 100
000 followers
oh aha oops greatest gift
test gif huh
so is there something something else is
it oh so now that she's dead
oh okay there's no time stamp here but
some they do know that she's dead
here's an opportunity you don't want to
miss my friends you see the way to
hustle smart is you got to fly close to
the sun
you got to find your role model and
orbit that sun like a mofo
that's how you're going to
here's your chance to get into my orbit
up close and personal
i'm looking for two ninja apprentices
people will pay hundreds of thousands to
get into this vortex but i'm not in this
for the money
i'm low buying this opportunity for you
it's cheaper than going to college let's
do this
okay
let's not do this i don't want to do
this
grab success by the throw
grab some chest might go through
for a mere price of ten
thousand dollars learn the
scientifically proven throat method
where you can turn your favorite pastime
into a professional career with the
amount of money you'll be making this is
a practically sustainable
wait okay ten thousand four hundred and
seventy two
times ten thousand zero zero
[Music]
you're telling me mr rex keegan has made
100
million dollars that's me sign me up
baby sign me
up
sorry we're full
i'm gonna grab you by the throat timed
holistic robust outstanding appreciation
technique
and then you can learn the advanced
d-e-e-p throat technique which stands
for
dick exclusive exciting penetration
time to holistic robust outstanding
appreciation technique
fuzzy throat there's so much here
there's it's done
all right whatever whatever whatever
jabber oh my god oh my god late for work
apology video i wish all my problems
could be solved with an apology video
for your anniversary apology video
straight up kill the dude apology video
i bet i could apologize my way out of a
murder maybe i already i have not
legally i'm saying that i have not sorry
if i offend anyone with my post now
let's move forward and on a more
positive thing i never wanted to avoid
being online until recently i don't
understand how people can come up with
such file things to say okay so that was
a lot of just me exploring the phone and
i did not get anything of value however
i have three downloads no no no no
maya's laptop oh forgot password yes i
did uh security questions what is the
greatest gift to you
[Music]
oh i know this one what is the greatest
gift to me i saw this wasn't this wasn't
it was in uh jabber
jabber greatest gift i heard i saw a
greatest gift
somewhere
here i've seen a greatest gift
greatest gift greatest gift
i don't remember anyway
uh right hello hi welcome back am i
going to the crime scene
long time since the last message i'm not
risking this covert operation by having
you trample all over the evidence in the
crime scene i'll give you access to the
police database you'll find everything
you need there i don't think i have
clearance
give me a moment ah that's what i was
missing this entire time okay clearance
granted database clearance granted get
it from warden okay i get it from warden
goddamn plumbers and they're stupid
questions i gotta go get your homework
before i get back
oh why the damn hell did you call the
emergency from her phone
look man i don't know
look man
[Music]
wow you weren't kidding about watching
me
good thing i am too you're in possession
of stolen evidence if they trace the
call back to that foam we're toast we
can't even afford live operators it's a
disgrace isn't it but don't change the
subject please just do your job instead
of poking around for your own amusement
i may have really poked around a lot for
my own amusement okay bye now what was
this about the database
victim name maya
whatever
bam
maya angelou i don't remember what was
the name
mum no you're not the right person maya
crane maya crane okay maya crane we're
looking for i believe from everything
that i've seen it's it's in october is
what you're looking for
bubbadoo
hey closed cases as you say was cl it
might have been closed and we're going
to reopen this bad boy
hey
there we go all right preliminary
compilation of investigation by west
bandricka pd
crane maya 25 female oh my god
[Music]
what is wrong with your face what
happened to you what happened to your
face
why
facial tears multiple faint scars across
the face leading all the way to the top
and back of the head as a whole these
scars appear to form a pat pattern
facial tears scars were deep and
extremely thin blood vessels around the
affected areas were cauterized possibly
explaining the absence of bleeding at
the time of death no other visible burn
injuries present head injuries slight
bruise to the back of the head suggests
that the deceased collapsed to the
ground from an upright position heart
tears tears in the muscle tissue around
the heart resembling spontaneous
coronary artery dissection cause of this
tearing is undetermined the manner of
death seems to be sudden in nature the
deceased possibly experienced a
momentary loss of control or
consciousness before collapsing on the
ground likely due to the sudden strain
on her heart the injuries are on the
face could not be determined cause of
death cardiac arrest aurelio cohen md
deputy chief minor
okay
ah hello
okay interview has been edited for
clarity good day ma'am oh my what is
going on is that maya's apartment yes
she was found dead this morning goodness
what happened that's what we're here for
did you see or hear anything last night
pardon did you see or hear anything last
night sorry dear these old eyes and ears
are not what they used to be i can
barely hear you right now can you please
repeat your question it's okay ma'am
thank you for your time have a nice day
why did you leave
mrs tench okay so what i need are more
uh transcripts evidence collected laptop
webcam dslr unknown device plastic
casing with three antennas looks like a
self-made signal boosters to modify wifi
or phone signals polaroid victim photo
of the victim and three acquaintances
mobile phone model a1901 hair strands of
various lengths all brunette one of them
is dyed purple very shoe imprints near
the entrance one of his men's rex guitar
picked no other musical instruments
present in the house
bagged at the crime scene by detecting
murillo sent to evidence room for
further processing
huh we need to search for transcripts
five two eight seven eight eight and
eight nine
oh
god that's creepy okey-dokey
wow my god why hello okay all right okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
i presume that you're done with the
files anything in there look normal to
you oh hold on hold on hold on i'm not
done yet i need to look up um
nah i'm not gonna find that in my
transcript type court document interview
uh
god what was it okay hi my hello again
okay it's a interview
number
5287 i'm gonna actually need to start
writing [ __ ] down aren't i five two
eight seven
bam
search
there we go now we got it okay miss
aria park
hello aria park this is her who's this
this is officer beck from west bendrica
pd i have a few questions for you um
okay what is this about what is your
relation to buy a crane we work together
doing social media stuff why what
happened i'm afraid to tell you that my
bed this morning
miss sorry i'm just i'm at a loss oh my
god what happened
we're working on it the reason i'm
calling is because we found hair samples
at the scene of the crime one of them
has dyed purple and it matched a picture
of you we found on maya he'd been to her
apartment recently not recently no i've
been there many times through
with some friends we all work together
maya's place was like a hub for us i
still can't believe she's dead loud sob
please officer mai is one of my best
friends you have to get to the bottom of
this we will ma'am just one more
question do you have any suspects what
else did you find are you bringing me in
for questioning you need to read me my
rights for that right please ma'am we're
just going through procedures i can't
discuss anything right now but i will
let you know if anything comes up i'm
just floored i understand where were you
on october 21st i was working tidying on
my resume okay so she died
october
2-1 okay hang on a second officer but am
i suspect no ma'am i'm just i already
told you i wasn't there and you keep
asking me questions so am i a suspect or
not
just protocol if i'm not a suspect can i
go please my friend just died and i need
to process this i understand sorry to
bother you hope you figure it out soon
okay
well that was fun is this gonna be rex
rex keegan
what up rex speaking okay have a moment
got an all day mellie crane found dead
like dead dead we work together
influencer oh you know mentions likes
it's quite certain she's dead is she
really really dead like did you check
come on man we worked together i've been
there loads of times
uh were you there recently i've seen my
for weeks what are you doing on the 21st
i was reading in my line of work got to
be up to date you got to read got to
learn you know that's all i need thank
you all right right gotcha
is being just outside her door count i
dropped off some hard drives she wasn't
home so i didn't really go in the house
that was the last last
that was the last last if you know what
i mean mina de silva oh very thorough
thank you
okay my crane manager
dead
loud screaming october 21st writing a
song just writing oh god maya that's all
right ma'am sorry we're done thank you
for so much so overwhelming okay
well that's all the three main friends
right so i've got all of these from the
three main friends okay detective
marillo everything looked normal what
the heck happened to her face
[ __ ] was she always like that it's our
job to figure it out
i can't tell if those are lacerations or
scars on her face never seen anything
like it attacked by a jealous lover
vampires and i mean that
super seriously
idiots
vampires leave bite marks on the neck ah
anyway those markings were not the cause
of death looks like old scars but from
what no sign of forced entry to hold on
i just got a bloop a blinkity blong i
got something
something here what is this
this is the last recorded video on the
phone before maya died details of the
crime scene in maya's deaths
huh
details of the crime scene
bam
how about that
take some of that with you
oh god what is this oh god wait to fix
this right
fix what
we're gonna have to destroy this thing
we have to
what
who's we
i think i have it figured out are you
gonna yoga it away
and we just need to get everybody here
well we can get rid of this thing
together it has to work it absolutely
has to work
if you're watching this
if we don't make it out alive
if we mess up and i don't make it out
alive
please watch the webcam footage
you'll see everything that you need to
see
okay am i seeing it right now
is it okay i didn't see anything
you didn't show me anything i didn't see
anything maya uh
any witnesses
did you even read the damn report i did
i did old lady cross hall confirms mai
was home at night last person to see her
alive
see
cctv
just our luck some interference fried
the apartment's entire network funny
thing same kind of interference we saw
in maya's video just weaker as if now
with nothing we have from the crime
scene leads to anything substantial our
best lead is still the phone there's
still more we don't know i can feel it
see you sound sure very sure that
there's more in the phone you sound very
sure that there's more on the phone
maya's entire life is in there her being
an influencer means that she must have
documented it neatly too that makes it a
great source
whoa
hang on warden is updating already why
be damned you found another clue already
getting ahead of me huh not bad
keep this up and you'll be climbing the
ranks in no time
hold on
hi
um did the cops contact anyone again
why are they poking around you tell them
anything
worried about something
[Music]
no way
who the hell is this
why do you have her phone identify
yourself now
guys it's me
maya
god this is the worst choice oh my god
maya you're ah god no this is some
screwed up prank yeah it is
oh god oh no why did i choose this one
don't be an idiot
whatever this is you better fess up
before i report you there's someone
interested in maya but not in that way
that that's that'd be weird
no i said not in that way i said not in
that way oh god i'm a detective
oh thank god
not cool scaring us like that hey
whatever this is normal procedure
we suspect foul play
oh my god that's horrible news pig
shouldn't
we've already spoken to the cops are we
like suspects
guys please
the police have any leads i was on a
semi-su
what do you know worried about something
no just curious
huh
interesting look dealing with this
publicly has been a nightmare for us
we're still in mourning you know
this is the drama over with asap all
right did any of you see her the day
that she died
kind of ghosted us for a bit
even with work stuff going on we ran an
influencer collective that maximized
follower roi and revolutionized content
circulation was maya's job giving her
trouble she's pretty worried about her
follower numbers yeah everything was
good till
how do i put this
until maya went
legit cuckoo
rex
she was acting kind of weird like she
went awol for a few days did she say
what happened she said she needed time
alone to decompress
maya said she wanted to quit the
business for good but i thought she was
just venting entrepreneurship is hard
man maybe she just couldn't handle it
thanks rex i just said she didn't tell
us how stressed she was
anything unusual happen at work uh same
old [ __ ] different day you know maya
always had high expectations of herself
i think that was her downfall too yeah
it sucks but some people just can't be
saved you know is that all
can i go now
for now hope you figure it out soon
let us know if you need anything else
thanks guys
later gators
[Music]
here
why is it all dark why you got your back
turned
ma'am
ma'am
ma'am
oh man don't do it
don't do it
i hate people that turn
oh boy you're still turning ain't you
maybe if i call 911
[Music]
man this phone is
[ __ ]
this phone's messed up
ah
hello
would rather work than cry and beg for
what we have jealousy is a terrible
disease okay
okay well that was interesting
um
hi the toxicity was unbearable what i'm
sure that i could
what
what the [ __ ] what
what
why
whoa okay let's look up the history
what kind of history are we looking at
hold on here hold on here hold on here
where's the porn where's the porn what
happens if i go to let's say
nope
nope and you don't have any like search
function i guess not all right what's up
doctor murillo
keep this up and you'll be climbing the
ranks no time looking through her phone
feels wrong
thank you sir
thank you very much sir
thank you
eager to get started sir whoa she
recorded this hours before she died
looks like she predicted her own death
she was planning to gather everyone her
friends her friends must have been at
the scene possible no way of telling if
their prints on the scenes are old or
new ones this webcam footage is her best
lead yet
it might reveal what she was talking
about but if it's on her laptop damn it
i can't risk breaking into the evidence
from again
don't you kids link everything in the
cloud these days look through her phone
there must be a way to i knew
oh
i think you've been doing some questions
who are these people who are these
people whose people whose people i knew
that there must be a way to get into
this
there's a way that i can find out what
your favorite thing in life is
i bet
i bet it's the question is greatest gift
to you
this
dump truck ass
[Music]
my
enormous left testicle
oh god
my greatest gift to me
oh that is honking but duncan
booty my thunderous thighs
my
house full of flies
the moment you say goodbyes
a large curly fries
huh
my
booty's
unrealistic
[Music]
size the mere existence of jazzercise
god i'm done
but there's got to be something here but
i will save this for the next episode of
simulacra 2 so thank you everybody so
much for watching i'm going to continue
this very soon we're going to get to the
bottom of this mystery i do like this
format i feel like there's like
you know i don't know i'm going to save
anything that i'm going to say about
until later but i i do like this format
i think it's very fun i think it's like
a nice play on um just general mechanics
i'm hoping for more spooky stuff
happening soon though so thank you and
as always i will see you
in the next video
bye
[Music]